hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now I
have already gone out and I got the
crash powder and I have the materials to
make the magnesium I was very dumb and
thinking that I needed to get that I
couldn't remember where and then I was
like oh yeah that's uh you make that
from salt so I've got enough salt to do
that I've got the crash powder and
weirdly enough every time I went to one
of those things they kept blowing
themselves up like the pod and all so I
had to go find a whole bunch before I
could find one that wasn't willing to
explode away all of its crash powder but
also before any of that I've got three
new lockers here the first one is the
only living virus one who said to spawn
in cute fish please it's like your own
pet and it follows you around now I
would do that but unfortunately I don't
want to cheat so what I'm gonna have to
do is I'm gonna have to see if cute fish
is in the game in general and then I'll
have a little floaty companion like
bubble butt but that's gonna be the name
of my seemeth when I get that again and
then there's gray lab coat 22 that said
what if the sea dragon is what destroyed
the other pods or it destroyed the
underwater base now I don't know where
the underwater base is because I've only
ever spawned there before through cheat
codes but when I find it it's more
likely that it was the Reaper Leviathan
that destroyed the other pods because
that's what's swimming around where I am
right now and able to kill me and stuff
so hahahahaha and then uh then knuckle
bust one zero one six three said what if
on April Fool's Day the Reaper was a
penis and ordinarily that wouldn't make
me laugh but we just played genital
jousting and I couldn't help think of
the the Reaper Leviathan as a giant
snake and dick floating through the
waters and that would be horrifying more
than it already is but either way I also
I want to reiterate I do not have the
diamond for the laser cutter and this is
a bit of a problem so the laser cutter
needed a diamond as well ever as
everything else but unfortunately I
think the diamond is down in like the
purple area and I tried I tried to go
down there I
my little glider I'm like I'm gonna go
down there I'm gonna hit a couple
outcrops and then come right back up
doesn't work you die I only got 75
seconds and blow their air starts going
away quickly
I even had my rebreather on and I tried
it twice and I died twice it did it just
didn't work so that's not gonna happen
for me so unfortunately that's just the
way that is so I need to put this stuff
away to make the magnesium Hobbit abou
ski Hobbit abou ski I'm gonna get out my
titanium from lemon Queen then I need
the tools I got the repair tool this is
enough to do at least one thing on the
Aurora and I can't remember if that was
the seamoth or if it was something else
but either way I'm gonna go back there
and try that because without the seamoth
I don't think I can get diamond I can't
go down low enough I just don't have
enough air the only other method which
which to do that would probably be to
make pipes and a floating air pump like
literally that's the only way that could
possibly think to get enough air to be
able to do that and I might actually do
that considering right next to me is the
sangar forest I don't even know if
that's the name of it it's the big
mushroom forest down below and there's
some Cyclops fragments down there so
that's my other option for this episode
when I went onto the Aurora I found a
bunch of logs and so there was just some
general things talking about the Aurora
and the people on the Aurora and how
they were looking forward to going home
finally and it's just bizarre because
there is a bigger universe being built
in this game and I'm not saying that's
weird I'm saying I appreciate it but
it's interesting that it's all hidden
into the environment and it's revealed
through these logs like you can see all
the wondrous technology that's around
you and you can see the benefit of that
throughout everything that you see in
your survival in everything that you're
crafting you're able to make things on
demand it's able to re materialize a
block of titanium into a floating air
pump that's incredible technology but
also it's interesting to see how this
all goes through the environment and how
you explore it and how you see it and
how you live it and how everything
around you is affected by it so it's
just something interesting in that I
love in
fire mental storytelling it's a bit
heavy-handed because it's like hey
here's some logs that tell you something
but I like the cleverness in that it
doesn't straight up tell you it tells
you through the voices of the people
that have all died and there's been a
lot of them on this big honkin ship you
can rest assured there's been a lot of
people that have died I just remember
there's only one other thing that I have
to do before I do that I need to take
these mushrooms I need to take the
copper that I found and I need to make a
few more batteries because I am
literally dead in the water for
batteries and I do not have the plans
necessary to build the charging station
or at least I'm assuming that's true I
mean maybe that's something that I could
actually build and I should probably
look before I make any bold claims as to
that and yes that's absolutely true I do
not have the stuff necessary to be able
to build the battery recharger I'm not
sure where that is but I'm pretty sure
that's probably gonna be on one of the
bases but I don't know if I'm gonna be
able to do that because I don't have a
seamoth to be able to explore things so
hahahahahahahahaha I'm a bunch of dead
so we're gonna get rid of all the
unnecessary things we have and then
we're good to go okay here we go we're
going for it yeah oh [ __ ] stop I don't
want any go away I'll see you when I get
back on the Aurora because I cannot
remember if the repair tool is
everything that I needed to be able to
get this one I think I had to have the
laser cutter but if I do then I gotta go
with the plan B which is the air pumps
and I don't want to have to go through
plan B
all right so I gotta go through this
infested [ __ ]
so seamoth pay it did oh it did it did
oh it did it did it only needed the
repair tool yes yes Open Sesame
oh hello hello my baby oh hello my baby
oh hello my baby pressure compensator
yes please oh no oh no what happened to
you what happened to you my baby oh no
oh yes oh yes oh yes okay so that wait
that's that's only two of three his last
one where's the last one where is it huh
no I was promised no well I don't know
where the last seamoth piece is it's not
down here because there's nothing left
to repair oh no wait there is but you
know I don't think it's like something
that's gonna be super crucial to what
I'm doing I guess I can repair all this
stuff because I might as well have the
repair tool I can stop the radiation
leakage at leakage and then I should be
able to do what I need to do to be able
to do everything else anyway it's a good
start I have the pressure compensator
which is something that I didn't know
that I was gonna be able to get down
here so that's gonna automatically allow
me to go even deeper and there were two
seamoth fragments down there I just
would have thought that there would have
been a third one ready to go but I guess
I was wrong okay let's start with this
one got this one ha ha
música last one and then all the
radiation should be gone which means
that I yes okay good I mean I don't know
how that hydrogen particle containment
field restored auto decontamination
sequence initiated
nice okay that answers a question our
estimate it to return to safe levels in
t-minus three days nice nice okay so
that's gonna do all that and that should
help us in regards to uh being able to
use a different suit when we're around
the Aurora but that still doesn't solve
my problem there is an entire piece of
the seamoth that's just missing and I
don't know where it is I don't think
it's behind anything I don't think like
it's burning in this wreckage over here
I don't think there's anything below
that I could find I don't think there's
another way in all this has been closed
off again that's not a way and that's
not a way in yeah now this is just fully
isolated which is for the best I mean it
was pretty easy to get in here it's it's
nice that it makes it a challenge and
you have to wait until it explodes
before you get in here and it's not just
a convenient passage I don't know it's
kind of nice like I appreciate it but
I'm just kind of like ah man I don't
know where to go for the other seamoth
piece like I need a welding thing to be
able to get through here and I just
don't have that for the prong ah okay
that's the prong Bay which is the
mechanical suit damn it I could have
sworn that it was gonna give me another
SEMA piece yeah either way that doesn't
help us so we got to keep moving you
know it doesn't help just a continually
flounder so we got to keep going at
least the Aurora's repaired at least we
have two pieces and just one pressure
compensator which is all good
not worried about that at all well so
there's gonna be okay we will find it
okay all right so we've got to I imagine
there are places outside of the Aurora -
fine
see the seamoth fragments I just don't
know where that's the only problem
I forgot there's a lot of aiya then
right here ye okay oh god I hate this
where is he where is he he's right here
I know he's right here Oh so what I'm
gonna do what I'm gonna do what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna deviate away from
the Aurora for just a hot second because
I know that there are more changes to
the map than have been foretold so I'm
gonna actually go in a different
direction that I've gone before to try
to find some new things because the I
need the laser cutter to be able to get
the prong I have to come back to the
Aurora at some point but right now I
don't have what I need and it's obvious
to me that the seamoth fragments are not
on the Aurora so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna deviate I'm gonna go back I'm
gonna pit stop here real quick so I can
drop off some stuff in exchange but what
I'm gonna do is I'm going to go probably
towards the other island via the
not-quite mountain range thing the not
Mountain the thing that's literally just
an underwater mountain that formed up
because I'm willing to bet there's
something on that second island than I
need and if the seamoth is there which
it might be I'm trying not to look
things up just because I want to play
this you know for truths ease but if
it's not there then oh well no big loss
I'm still in a new area but if there's
some resource there like a diamond that
I can get that is useful then hey that's
not too bad so we're just gonna find it
we're gonna play it by ear and we're
gonna find it okay
I have food I have water I have a health
kit I have less than ideal batteries but
hey you know swimming by myself ain't
too bad so if my
my thing is over there I believe the
mountain ranges generally in this
direction so I'm gonna have to go past
my good buddies the giant screaming
floating bastards oh there you are
terrifying as they may be I do believe
they are key to my journey I'm out of
power on that one okay you wouldn't
happen to have any batteries would you
no all right have a nice day
I think I've explored this wreck before
but if I haven't I'm gonna take a quick
game caution
thirty seconds of oxygen remaining thank
you Karen yes yay I'm second books I
can't make that can i oh [ __ ] me oh [ __ ]
me Oh way whoa Wow
that was freakin close Thank You Eclipse
holy [ __ ] that was awesome okay so what
that did I now have the plans for the
seamoth I do but then I suddenly
realized I can't make that I don't have
the mobile vehicle bait - why
I do not I don't know I don't ah that's
a second tits ain't it oh that's a sack
of baloney
oh boy yeah mitt okay so I do not have
the mobile vehicle babe where the Frick
of frack do you get the mobile vehicle
bay I don't frickin frackin no you know
what I'm just gonna keep the course from
where I was going I believe the mountain
ranges over this way let's keep plowing
forward because frankly hey we got the
seamoth and that's not too bad we don't
have have it but we have can build it
ooh hello you are big oh so you're a big
wreck okay so I'm gonna explore this bad
boy there might be something of value in
here yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] so I just stop it
stop it stop ACK are you [ __ ] stop
that was a battery charger [ __ ] [ __ ]
freakin douche bags I think that was a
battery charger did that say that was if
that was a battery charger I am in
golden shape I will be so happy man
those things are just hanging around
that battery charger Oh goddamn it
ah [ __ ] I'll take a bite light stick
that's not what I wanted where to go
where to go where to go oh god oh god oh
god oh god I'm dancing I'm dancing I'm
dancing what's in here first aid kit yes
I need that I'm gonna need that oh [ __ ]
ow ow ow ow owie owie ow ow where the
[ __ ] was it Oh God where the fight just
[ __ ] disappeared are you kidding me
Oh what are you Tiger plant stop [ __ ]
stop everything wants to kill me so
badly every everything absolutely wants
to annihilate my face Jesus
this is [ __ ] awful oh my god
and I gotta stop that that pod doing
severe brain damage and this is the most
aggressive things have been in this game
I do not appreciate it why are you all
around here
stop chasing after me I don't know what
that was not David I couldn't find it
again or is there way in here in this
piece of wreckage something good for me
maybe okay what's in here
oh that sounds bad oh it's a dead end
oh okay that's okay I'm sorry
yeah I'm sorry okay all right okay then
got away in God why do I keep getting
put I think I think my yah I think my C
glider just got damaged is that even a
thing that can happen oh it seems
damaged it's not what that static is no
okay it was just on the fritz
alrighty then everything's back to
normal now I think what is that that is
definitely a thing are you
mobile vehicle BAE Oh was that what that
thing I was that I found god damn these
sharks it's light stick I don't need a
light stick I don't need a light stick I
don't need a light stick [ __ ] stop oh
wow oh I don't want to go in there I
can't go in there
remaining god damn it they're just
[ __ ] everywhere
but I found a piece of the mobile
vehicle Bay this is not going to any
faster emergency okay
I'm [ __ ] just god dammit I do not
understand what's happening with my c
glide it is very broken and I am gonna
die here we go not quite okay holy Sh
but there's the island that wasn't there
before okay Wow
what is happening to me what is
happening to me I don't know I don't
know I just want to find the rest of the
mobile vehicle bay fragments they are
definitely here but I don't know if I'm
gonna be able to find them all in time
before I run out of air I definitely
don't want to get trapped going down
here but [ __ ] I can't even go in there
but I see another piece [ __ ] I don't get
in there I don't know
goddammit wide oh I don't know if I just
pick like the world's worst particular
wreck to explore but I'm in a lot of
trouble here and I barely have any time
and I'm out completely out of batteries
can only hope this is gonna pay out for
me okay here we go bioreactor nice I
like it okay that's one mobile vehicle
Bay I like it that's another plant pot
not what I needed no what I need was it
it's a mobile vehicle a battery charge
[ __ ] not what I needed but it's okay
I'll take it so I did I did see battery
charger oh yes yes yes yes okay that's
so good that is so good oh and another
battery charger I can just make out this
one and then I'm gonna get the [ __ ] back
yes yes yes oh man that was so difficult
oh my god okay we got the mobile vehicle
Bay and the battery charger which are
two things that we absolutely did need I
mean I got something in my eye like
right at the end there was like yeah
victory okay here's something to stab
you in your cool
Neah thank you I definitely wanted a
piece of debris inside my ocular orifice
anyway we got what we needed I'm gonna
head back I'm gonna build all this stuff
and in the next episode we are gonna
have a seamoth and the means with which
to finally explore the deep depths yes
bubble butt is gonna make his grand
return or her it's a chip I don't think
they have genders it doesn't matter
I've got it and everything is gonna be
okay
maybe we I don't know maybe 100 percent
maybe that's a sobbing i'ma put a solid
maybe on that one I actually do not know
but either way that is all the time that
I have for this episode we've made some
good progress here like some seriously
good progress and we've had a lot of
serious trouble along the way but I will
forgive this game for doing that for me
it is still being a son of a [ __ ] but
you know it's the kind of son of a [ __ ]
you got to have around for Thanksgiving
so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you thought
down in the comments below and as always
I will see you in the next video bye-bye
[Music]